- [Mark] All right, Quiera
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Or also known
as Kelly on my channel.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That was your street
name that you asked me to use
- Yeah
- [Mark] Back then.
- [Mark] But a lot has gone
on since you and I spoke
almost a year ago.
- [Quiera] Yeah.
- [Mark] That was Christmas
Eve that you and I met.
So first, before we even
get into what's going on
in your life today,
let's address there was this kind of,
I don't know, what to call it,
but a lot of peoples claimed
your story was untrue.
And I have my ideas as
to why that happened.
What are your thoughts on it?
- Honestly, I just think
people, they don't know.
Honestly, they think
that I did it for money.
- [Mark] Well, you didn't
do it for the money.
Cause you didn't know
that there was a GoFundMe
connected to your campaign.
- But people don't know that.
- [Mark] That was something
I didn't tell anyone
you didn't know.
- But people don't know that.
So they assume that, you
know, that I did it for money
- [Mark] It was actually, I
told you when it was $12,000
and you told me to stop
it at 13,000, I think.
- Yeah
- [Mark] Which I didn't do.
I let it go to 28.
In two days it went up to
28,000 and then I stopped it.
- It went up really fast.
So of course people
thought I did it for money
and for clout, but I don't care.
I don't let things like that phase me
because I know what I've
been through, you know.
- [Mark] Yeah. I learned a lot
from social media through you
because I was ready to let's do a video
and show the scars in front of your ears.
Let's show them the paperwork
showing your foster system history
and show them this, that and the other.
And you said, no, don't do a thing.
Just let it go.
Haters are gonna hate
- Cause I knew like it would die down.
And then I have more believers
than, you know, accusers.
So it's just like, I don't care.
I know my truth.
I know what I've been through.
So I'm not gonna let people
that don't even know me
you know...
- [Mark] Here's a couple
of things to consider
if anyone is doubting your story.
If you had a tight
relationship with your ...
Apparently there were
pictures of you and your mom
or your grandma
- And me and my mom
- [Mark] On Facebook.
Your mom is still alive.
- Right.
- [Mark] So you can get
together for the holidays.
You can take a picture with your mom.
- Yeah, for holidays.
- [Mark] It's Facebook,
that's what people do.
- Yeah. That's why they're posted.
Those are times that obviously
meant something, you know.
- [Mark] But if you had
a tight relationship
with your family, why would
you be spending Christmas
with a white dude that
you met the day before?
Why would you...
- I didn't spend my Christmas with anyone,
but my boyfriend.
- [Mark] Why would you be
living on the street in a tent
for a month?
For a month you were doing
that, two months maybe.
- Yeah, I don't know, people...
- [Mark] Whatever.
There's a Washington post article,
I'll leave another link of the description
people can read it and see
that your story is true
except you've got the year
of your foster system wrong.
You were, you said it was six
and it was five or vice versa.
I'm not sure what.
- But I was young at age, you know,
so of course I'm just speaking
what I've been through,
you know
- [Mark] So let's move on.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I love the way you handled it though.
- Thanks.
- [Mark] I learned a lot from that.
So you got $28,000 bit by
bit through the GOFUNDME.
I'm sure you appreciate all the donors.
- Definitely. I appreciate that.
Thank you to everyone that supported.
Thank you to all the ones that
actually believe my story.
You know, the ones that
are actually genuine.
I appreciate it.
It really helped me out.
I was able to get an apartment.
I was able to get a car, you know
it really helped me get on my feet.
- [Mark] Yeah. And you've
done a great job since then,
as we'll get into.
You're now living in an apartment
far from South central LA,
far from Skid Row,
- Yeah
- [Mark] In a neighborhood
that's very safe and normal
- It'll be a year that
I've been living there
two in February.
- [Mark] Yeah, no,
you're doing a great job.
You and I speak almost every
at least once or twice a week
now every week.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And I see what you're doing.
I see how hard you're working.
You've had three jobs
since this all happened.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] We helped you get off
the street, that donors did
and myself, we got you
into this situation.
- Of course you.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- I said of course you too.
You helped so much.
- [Mark] I do my part.
- People always ask
me, does Mark help you?
Hey does that guy help you?
I'm always like, yeah.
Like he helps me a lot, a lot.
- [Mark] Yeah. But I don't
want this to be about...
I don't want this to
turn into a help channel
- Of course. But yeah.
- [Mark] So I turned the nutshell down,
I don't wanna show that stuff.
So, but I do help people.
But you got one job and then COVID came
and you lost that job because
they closed the stores
you were working in.
you got another job, and then
the same thing happened again.
And today you're working as what?
- A caregiver for the elderly
- [Mark] For like Alzheimer
patients and things like that.
- Dementia, you know, bedridden people,
all different types of you know,
I don't know all of the terms yet,
cause I'm still in training.
You know, I still have to
obtain those certificates
and things like that.
So I'm going to those classes to obtain...
- [Mark] And your working six day a week?
- Yeah six days a week.
I'm tired.
- [Mark] You're tired today
because you were just...
- Yeah, I'm tired.
It's my off day, I'm tired.
- [Mark] Yeah. But so, you
know, cause I've interviewed
I think I counted it yesterday.
I've interviewed like over 200 women
that work the streets
mostly on Figueroa Street.
And what got you out?
I mean you're very different
than all the other girls
who are still working the street
they haven't broken free of that lifestyle
and you were determined to do it.
- Honestly. I think for me,
it's because I didn't wanna be
in that lifestyle, you know.
Like that wasn't something that
I wanted to continue doing.
I felt the pain of that lifestyle.
You know, I felt the
struggle of that lifestyle.
So it's like, you know, I
didn't wanna do that anymore.
I wanted to change, you know I watch TV
or I watch social media,
and I see different things
that I wanna obtain,
I wanna be in life.
So I just pretty much didn't
wanna do that anymore.
So that's why I stopped.
And I came down here you know,
I went away from you know, my last guy
and I came down here to get away,
I met you and now I'm
here, you know, thank God.
So I think it was just pretty much me
not wanting to be down there.
And then on top of that, you
know, I'm like in my head,
I'm headstrong
- [Mark] You are very headstrong.
And I think that's the real key
to what helped you be so
focused and determined
from breaking out.
Cause all the other girls
that I've spoken to...
- And then I think reading books too.
- [Mark] Yeah. You read a lot.
But a lot of the girls
that I've interviewed
that worked the streets mostly on Figueroa
have very very similar stories to yours.
- Yeah, I would imagine.
- [Mark] And their stories, the
dates are a little different
the abuse was slightly different
but basically a very
similar story to yours.
They started at a very young age and so on
but they're still doing it.
And you are so kind of focused
and determined and hardheaded
in a good way,
- Yeah
- [Mark] Of making a
decision and sticking to it.
Because I know there were times when...
Because we had problems with GOFUNDME,
because of all the claims that you lying,
the GOFUNDME they
wouldn't release the money
for a long time.
So I had to keep supporting you
but it got really awkward at one point
where I was like, man,
I'm just bleeding money.
And there was no sign that
GOFUNDME was gonna cooperate.
- Right.
- [Mark] And all the negativity
that you were getting
made GOFUNDME go, well,
I think this is a scam
because everyone was saying it was a scam.
My other thought that
I didn't say earlier,
on other reaction to
your video not being true
I almost think when some viewers,
and you gotta understand, this
is a very small percentage
but when some viewers
watch a video like yours
where here's somebody
who is fighting adversity
and doing the right thing for themselves
and that can be getting
off the streets as you did,
stopping using drugs as you did.
But it could also be, you know
all the problems people
have in relationships
and putting up with less than, you know
and they see what they're
not doing in your video
like you're doing what
they should be doing.
And rather than deal with that,
they lash out at you and
try to knock you down.
And I think that might've
been the real thing
that was going on with your video.
- [Quiera] I thought of that too.
- [Mark] Cause your story is no different
than anyone else's really
- [Quiera] Something similar to that.
- [Mark] But you got the GOFUNDME
and they saw you doing the right thing.
And it's like the whole
thing just made everyone go,
(chuckles)let's knock her down.
- [Quiera] Yeah.
- [Mark] I think there was a lot of that.
- [Quiera] Cause some people may like,
they may look at the video
and they're probably like,
wow I just can't imagine
this girl going through
all of those things.
So they don't believe it, or
some people may not be happy
with themselves, you know,
so they may not believe it.
But honestly I never dwelled on the people
that didn't believe me.
I never,
- [Mark] No, you never did.
- [Quiera] I never cared about the people
that didn't believe me,
I only care and I only respond to people
that are supporters or
that are being genuine.
I never really know who's
really being genuine
but if you're portraying
yourself to be genuine
and you're being kind and
you're coming to me with respect
then of course, you
know if I see, you know,
I'll definitely reach back
out and say, thank you
and what I appreciate.
I've never dwelled on
the negative comments.
- [Mark] Your story is
also so heartbreaking.
It's hard for some people to deal with.
- [Quiera] Right.
- [Mark] You had nothing.
Nobody's helping you in any way
and it's like you persevered
and were unwilling to compromise.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And that's almost
what I think the quality
that you possess that really
helped you break free.
Cause now you're living a
very very different life
than you did before.
- And that support, you
know, I was in a low space.
I was suicidal.
I was a lot, but I came through
with you know, meeting you,
you know, stuff like that.
- [Mark] Your boyfriend?
- Yeah. And so...
- [Mark] I'm just very proud of you.
I think you have all the
tools to thrive in life.
You just needed a little headstart,
which is what we gave you.
What do you think helped you the most?
I mean I think it's your personality
of being very hard-nosed and...
- Helped me the most with what?
- [Mark] Just getting your life straight
because so many people can't and don't.
- I think my mindset and
like you said my personality.
Really more so my mindset
I will see things that I want
and things that I wanna do.
You know, it's not fun being
out on the street all day,
you know, selling your body,
it's degrading, it gets
tiring, it gets painful.
So, you know, of course, as a young woman,
well any young woman in her right mind
is gonna think, hey I don't wanna do this.
Well, you should, you know.
I feel like that's not
something that you just...
But there's a difference, some
girls they enjoy doing that
you know, it's fun to them.
It was never fun to me, so, you know.
- [Mark] But what advice would
you give to a young woman
who's considering doing
something like this?
- Definitely don't do it.
You know, it's degrading, you know,
it's degrading to yourself,
it comes to a point where
it's degrading to yourself
and then, you know, you're
just better than that.
You definitely don't wanna sell your body,
you're better than that.
There's plenty of other
things that you can do
to get what you need,
get the support you need.
Definitely don't need to do that.
I would never tell a young woman
or a girl to sell her body.
I would never.
- [Mark] What are the
positives and negatives of...
Cause there are some
positives to that lifestyle
with a lot of negatives.
Are you happier today than you were then?
- Definitely.
- [Mark] I would think so
What are the positives and
negatives of each lifestyle?
Cause you're living a
very different life now
- The positives of that lifestyle,
I would only say it's
the fast money, I guess.
- [Mark] And there's lots
of negatives with it.
- But there's hell of negatives.
So out of a hundred, there's that 1% good
and then there's the 99 of that.
That lifestyle comes with a lot.
You get in a car with someone
and that person, you don't know
what kind of tip they're on,
but next thing you know,
you have a gun to your head,
you know, and you're getting raped.
So it's just like that
lifestyle is not the lifestyle
that you wanna live.
It's not safe for one, it's
not safe for your health
it's not safe for your security.
And it's degrading.
- [Mark] So the downside
of where you're at today
is maybe you're making
a little less money.
It's not fast money.
It's slow money.
- It's uncle Sam's money.
(Mark laughs)
- Yes, yes, he takes a fine.
But what are the upsides of your new life?
- I'm happier, I'm in a better space.
You know, I'm not degrading myself.
The moves that I make are
based off of my own mindset.
You know, I'm just moving
with love and care,
I'm in a better space.
People that are around me,
they're loving and caring.
So I'm just in a better space.
I'm working,
I'm gonna be moving soon
so I'm just happy.
I'm just building for my future.
- [Mark] It's been beautiful
to watch your transformation
from a lot of depression, a lot of stress
a lot of negativity and just difficulty.
And now you're like much more
positive, happier, mellow
and calm.
- Oh my gosh, thank you.
But literally, I don't know
why I just thought about
how people say, oh, she's lying.
She has braces, braces cost $4,000.
Like what?
No, they don't.
My braces are only two thousand.
- [Mark] But if you
look at the other videos
of all the girls that
do that for a living,
many of them had braces.
Many of them have very expensive nails,
or very expensive shoes.
- And they act like there
aren't payment plans.
I pay hundred dollars
a month for my braces.
- [Mark] No, no, it's not
about the...It's the facts
- It's just funny
- [Mark] Yeah I know.
- It's just funny, cause as I
was smiling, I felt my braces.
And then I know we're doing an interview,
so I just thought of that.
- [Mark] Haters want to hate.
That's what it's about I think.
What regrets do you have in your life?
- I wouldn't say I have regrets
I would say I have lessons learned
because without me
going through the things
that I went through and
without me going through things
I wouldn't have learned a lesson,
I wouldn't know not to do that, you know.
I wouldn't know oh, no, don't do that
because this is gonna be the outcome.
So I just take everything as a lesson,
I kind of pretty much try
to live with no regrets,
but I just take everything
as a lesson learned.
And if I take an L I eat it,
I eat it like a grown woman
you know, but other than that,
I know I've been through some things
I know I've had, you know
dirt on my name at a time,
but because of that but other than that,
I don't really have many regrets.
- [Mark] Just made you stronger.
- Yeah, what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And how's your relationship
with your mom today?
- We're good.
We're really good.
You know, we talk, I hit her up every day
and stuff like that, so we're great.
- [Mark] I mean the foster
system story you told
was horrifying, what do you
think the solution is to that?
- Honestly, I think
that the social workers
need to be more active in
the foster children's lives.
And there shouldn't always be meetings,
like when the social worker
comes to visit the child
it shouldn't just be a meeting
with the foster parents
the child and the social worker.
It should be a point where
it's just the social worker
and the child,
so the child can feel safe
enough to express themselves.
And then on top of that, when
they do express themselves
and the social worker knows
that it's gonna be a little
timeframe before something can be done.
They shouldn't expose or give a reaction
to what the child just said,
because it kind of, you know
it kind of like tells on
what the child just says.
You know I just feel like it
should be more confidentiality
and if I'm saying that word right.
Did I say it right?
- [Mark] You did.
- Yeah. And I feel like
they should just be more
so in their lives and there
should be more visits.
It shouldn't just be once a month.
It should be probably about three a month,
three visits a month, I would say.
- [Mark] All right Quiera,
thank you so much for coming in again.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You didn't want
to come in for a long time.
Cause it was just, there's so much like...
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Attention.
Your video got like
almost 6 million views.
- I don't need that.
- [Mark] You don't need that.
Nobody needs that.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It was crazy.
Probably go viral again.
- [Mark] No, no, no.
- Hopefully this one is...
- [Mark] This one's inspirational
- [Quiera] It's for the,
you know, believers.
- [Mark] Yes.
- [Quiera] Yeah.
- [Mark] You're amazing,
I'm so proud of you.
- [Quiera] Thank you. I appreciate it.
(indistinct chatter)